why's Bitcoin a fraud governments they
like to control the currency they
control through a central bank maybe
these things get they close it down
after speaking out about Bitcoin last
month Jamie Dimon was called a crony an
ignoramus a liar and a fool bitcoin
can't be shut down because it doesn't
have a CEO or corporate headquarters
it's a sophomore network that runs on
computers spread around the globe so any
efforts to close it down would resemble
a game of whack-a-mole here's the other
point Jamie Dimon doesn't understand
Bitcoin is free speech and in the u.s.
at least it can't be made illegal thanks
to the First Amendment
that's because bitcoin is just code and
code is just speech which is based on
legal precedent established during the
so called crypto Wars of the early 90s
one of the first showdowns took place in
1993 when Phil Zimmermann faced possible
criminal charges for writing the
encryption software PGP the government
said that it was as dangerous as guns
and bombs to make the point that PGP
source code is protected speech MIT
press printed it in a book sold it
abroad and Zimmermann was never indicted
then in 1995 mathematician Daniel
Bernstein sued the US government on
First Amendment grounds for blocking
publication of his encryption program
computer language is just that language
wrote Judge Marilyn Hall Patel
ultimately the Ninth Circuit Court
affirmed Patel's ruling the code has the
same constitutional protections as a
poem or newspaper article the First
Amendment protects users who keep their
own bitcoins printed on a sheet of paper
or stored in the software wallet but it
doesn't preclude regulatory regimes like
the New York bit license which
constrains the activities of third party
companies that maintain other people's
crypto holdings but these firms are
vestige of the old world financial
system if the world transitions from a
dollar standard to a Bitcoin standard by
then software will have evolved to make
it easier for users to maintain and
trade their own cryptocurrency without
involving a regulated company and those
activities have the same constitutional
protections as other forms of
controversial speech the money can now
be expressed in strings of numbers and
letters that don't require a government
sanctioned bank to
invalid poses a mortal threat to the
existing financial industry is it any
wonder that the CEO of the world's sixth
largest bank wants to believe that the
government can step in and offer
protection
[Music]